we have not done anything to the
non-governmental organizations that are
getting federal uh grant money and and
they're becoming the travel agencies for
these illegal immigrants they're the
ones put them on buses putting them on
planes giving them 13 to 1400 each of
taxpayer money and so we should be able
to revoke those licenses of these 501 c3
organizations like a catholic charities
that is operating uh and aiding and
abetting human and sex trafficking here
in the state of texas so there are many
things that a governor could do
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
retired army lieutenant colonel chairman
of the republican party of texas and
candidate for governor of texas
alan west welcome back to the reuben
report
good to be with you dave and merry
christmas i have to make one correction
i stepped down from being the chairman
uh back in june right before i announced
the run for governor because i didn't
want any conflict of interest but uh
everything is going very well here in
texas
well merry christmas to you and i like
being corrected by the guest on the very
first sentence of an interview i feel
we're not going to edit i always tell my
guests we don't edit for content so i
like it you're setting the tone uh i
appreciate the fact check on that how
are you my friend you know i realized
like a minute before we started here
that we've actually never done the
one-on-one you've been on the show once
you were on with chad robichaud we were
talking about all the work that you guys
do with veterans but we've actually
never done the one-on-one that was a
couple years ago you've had an
interesting uh couple of years
yeah it's been
yeah it has been an interesting couple
years i you know by the grace of god i
probably should not be here because the
last year memorial day weekend i had an
accident on my motorcycle 75 miles an
hour on interstate highway and uh you
know the fact that i'm still alive is
very uh very great and so it's a
pleasure to be here with you and
everything and i'm down here in
livingston texas at dfw post 8568 and i
love coming you know getting out of the
big cities and getting down to the small
rural areas and especially being with
veterans what a what a great thing to do
is as you know as we go into the holiday
season also yeah and you guys do some
tremendous work with veterans before we
get into everything you're doing now and
why you're running for governor and of
texas and everything else uh could we
just do the quick uh two-minute bio on
you and your story your service that
sort of thing just so those those that
don't know you will fully know you and
then we'll go from there
well i gotta tell you when you think
about the american dream and everything
that america offers to each and every
one of us i call it the equality of
opportunity not the quality of outcomes
you know 60 years ago i was born in a
blacks only hospital in the inner city
of atlanta georgia i grew up in the same
neighborhood they gave us dr marliss the
king jr there in atlanta
my dad was a world war ii corporal
united states army and he served this
country at a time when he was not seen
equal to everyone in a segregated army
my mother did 25 years plus civilian
service with the marine headquarters in
atlanta my older brother was an
infantryman and marine corps and was
wounded in vietnam at the age of 15 my
dad challenged me to be the first
officer in our family and on 31 july
1982 i was commissioned as a second
lieutenant at the university of
tennessee i served 22 years active duty
service for the united states army as a
field artillerman also as a paratrooper
13 different countries three different
combat zones
the story for our family doesn't end
there my uh nephew who is my older
brother's son he is now a lieutenant
colonel in the united states army
continuing to serve i've been married
for 32 years i have a great wife she's
really the brain trust of this this
couple she has an mba and a phd and i
met her when she was a business
professor at kansas state university we
had two daughters uh aubry and austin 28
and 24 and six months ago we became
grandparents to an incredible
little grandson by the name of jackson
bernard so that's pretty much so my life
and you know i had a great opportunity
to serve in the state of florida as a
united states congressman
and back in 2004 i got the opportunity
to come back to texas my last duty sign
was fort hood texas and so here i am now
running to be the governor of the state
of texas well you definitely handled the
resume question well so uh let's talk a
little bit about the states because you
mentioned the sort of big two or the
shining stars at least from where i'm at
at the moment as you know i'm in crazy
los angeles california as we tape this
uh but you mentioned florida where you
were a congressman you're running for
governor in texas
are you
sort of pleased to see the way the
states have gone in different directions
at this point that the federalist system
is sort of working when you see hubs of
freedom like florida and texas and i'll
throw tennessee in there and a couple
other states
while you watch some of the blue states
kind of crumble
well the interesting thing is i think we
need to reassert that sense of
federalism and what we see as far as
that understanding of the 10th amendment
where it says that those powers not
delegated to the federal government are
reserved to the states and to the people
and that's where we have a huge
constitutional crisis here in the state
of texas because article 4 section 4 of
the constitution there are two things
that the federal government is supposed
to guarantee to every state in the union
number one a republican form of
government not republican party but
republican form of government and number
two they're supposed to protect every
state from invasion well when you have
an administration like we see with the
bible administration that has abdicated
their constitutional duty and
responsibility to protect the
sovereignty of texas and the sovereignty
of the united states of america texas
has a 1 254 mile border with a foreign
country and it is not just an everyday
foreign country it's a destabilized
foreign country and we see this
transnational narco criminal terrorist
organization known as the cartels really
running things along our border and so
the founding fathers and their
brilliance gave the state the ability to
be able to protect itself if the federal
government abdicated that and so i think
that's one of the things we see here in
texas and many of the other red states
is to once again reassert that ideal of
federalism uh this the federal
government is supreme over the states by
the supremacy clause but it has to be
that they're doing things pursuant
they're up to the constitution and i
would challenge anyone when we see this
by the administration they're not doing
too many things pursuant to the
constitution
is the border issue you think that's the
number one issue on texans minds i mean
it's a little hard to gauge because on
one hand you can sort of only see the
videos on fox or online mainstream won't
cover it and then it makes it a little
hard to see well what is the average
person seeing do they even know what
they're voting on because they're not
seeing it depending on what news they
watch
well i will tell you that you talk to
people down here in texas and especially
you talk to people on the border
counties they will tell you that's the
number one thing and i think that it
really came to a forefront nationally as
an issue when we saw those airplanes
that landed in the middle of the night
in westchester county new york that had
illegal immigrant minor children and
those planes took off from texas and we
also know that there are planes that
have been landing in florida where i
think you may be looking to come we want
you to come here to texas i don't want
you going for it but we told you to make
the hard sell man
i'm gonna make you an offer you can't
refuse but you know we we've seen those
planes land in florida we've seen those
plants land in tennessee and how
interesting there are those planes are
landing in red states those planes are
landing in suburban areas but most uh
definitely we need to realize that the
united states of america right now has
an all-time high in drug overdoses over
100 000 of our young people drug
overdoses and other where is that coming
from the fentanyl and how is fentanyl
getting to the united states of america
from china down to mexico across the
border here so we got a drug trafficking
crisis we have a human and sex
trafficking crisis texas is the number
one state in america for human sex
trafficking dallas and houston uh maybe
you don't want to move into dallas but
we can talk about suburbs but dallas and
houston are the top two cities in the
country for sex trafficking and we know
about the public health crisis think
about this dave i mean we've got a
federal government that's telling us
law-abiding american citizens what we
have to get injected into our bodies but
people are coming across 200 000 a month
and no one is telling them they have to
have anything injected in their body so
we have a public health crisis as well
were you beyond shocked when about a
week ago maybe 10 days ago when anthony
fauci was asked about just that and you
know they're talking about a mandate on
planes for domestic travel on trains and
then the reporter wisely asked him well
what about the people at the border and
he basically was like ah that's a
separate issue altogether not for you
guys
no it's not for us it's very dismissive
and if you want to look at spikes where
we've seen covet here in the state of
texas you just follow the places where
we have a lot of concentrations of
illegal immigrants going to to include
out in west texas they've been bussing
illegal immigrants out in west texas
putting them up in hotels and in the man
camps or some of the oil and gas field
workers and you've seen a spike out
there in midland and odessa you see it
in the major cities like like in houston
there's an estimation that the
population of houston has increased
somewhere between 300 000 to 400 000
because there's a pipeline of folks
coming across the border illegally
somehow getting transported and then
they are bunkered down in houston or
some of these other places in these
stash houses so we have a huge issue
that we have to deal with
so the easy version of this for guys
like us would be okay the biden
administration wants to destroy america
you know the democrats want to flood the
country it's all about demographics or
voting patterns or keep the people on
the dole et cetera i mean do you think
it's as simple as all that or is there
something is this ineptitude is this
that these people just don't know how to
govern don't know what they're doing or
do you think it's something you know
directly nefarious
it is nefarious it's intentional and
purposeful because when i look at this
open borders agenda that was implemented
uh unconstitutionally i mean you cannot
give up the sovereignty of the united
states of america by executive order but
then you look at hr1 and what h.r 1
talks about because both of them came
about at the same time and h.r 1 says
that there will be no voter registration
role review there will be no picture id
that we will be doing voting by
unsolicited mail-in ballots and online
voter registration same-day voter
registration same-day voting and it does
talk about illegals being able to vote
and you look at this infrastructure the
human infrastructure bill where they're
talking about granting amnesty and so by
the end of this year we will be looking
at close to two million illegal
immigrants this is a record high for the
united states of america have crossed
the board and come into this country so
i'm sure some people are watching going
well wait a minute abbott's a republican
he's he's over there has he dropped the
ball on this
without a doubt you have to wonder why
the governor has done a lot better and
we could have seen this coming that's
what leadership is all about leadership
is about having vision and being very
prescient and so you should have taken
all the measures necessary to ensure
that you had our own texas military
department our national guard ready to
secure our border and make sure that we
did not see this flood of illegals
coming here we needed to make sure that
we could stand on our constitutional
right article 1 section 10 clause 3 to
be able to secure our border and i think
another thing an executive order from
the governor state of texas to declare
these cartels as a terrorist
organization because you know i was in
iraq i was in afghanistan and you know
in afghanistan the taliban uses opium as
a means to uh you know fuel their their
their efforts and so what are they doing
here they're using fentanyl
methamphetamines marijuana so it's the
exact same thing we're fighting an
insurgency and they're shooting across
the border into the state of texas which
is an act of war if you declare them as
a terrorist organization then you go
after their resources and their finances
you go after their assets you freeze it
and you seize it we have not done
anything to the non-governmental
organizations that are getting federal
uh grant money and and they're becoming
the travel agencies for these illegal
immigrants they're the ones putting them
on buses putting them on planes giving
them 13 to 1400 each of taxpayer money
and so we should be able to revoke those
licenses of these 501 c3 organizations
like a catholic charities that is
operating uh and aiding and abetting
human and sex trafficking here in the
state of texas so there are many things
that the governor could do are you
surprised how bad everything's gotten
under biden obviously you didn't vote
for biden but are you shocked at you
know only 11 months in just just sort of
across the board how bad it is
no i'm not because this is what
progressive socialism is all about and
you know when i was in congress uh back
in 2011 2012 you know i just looked at
what they believed in i looked at their
policies i looked at their ideological
agenda and i called them out as
socialist marxists some of them even
communists and of course you remember i
mean people went sideways on me for that
but guess what happens now today they
tell you we're socials we're marxists
and so when you look at that philosophy
of governance i'm not surprised by what
they're doing uh they're doing exactly
what they uh what they believe in what
they say the the fascism the uh the
suppression of free speech and freedom
of expression you know calling parents
who just want to stand up and make sure
that their kids get a good education
domestic terrorists and that's even
happening here in texas where we have
had two parents in round rock just north
of austin they were arrested in their
homes for just going and speaking out at
a school board meeting this is not the
america this is not the texas that
people want you know i got to do a mayo
culpa here man because i remember when
you were talking about this stuff way
back when and i was a lefty and i was on
the young turks at the time and i'm sure
i did videos on their channel it's
probably saying that you were nuts you
know because you saw it early and and i
wasn't there yet so uh times change i
suppose
well you know they in ecclesiastes uh
king solomon said there's nothing new
under the sun and george santayana once
said those who fail to learn from
history are doomed to repeat it and and
i think that's the important thing again
about leadership and being a statesman
you have to say things that people need
to hear not what they want to hear and i
was willing to take the heat because uh
look i i in 1985 i went through
checkpoint charlie and i went over to
east berlin and i saw what it was like
and my background is in political
science political theory and uh this is
textbook stuff what we see happening
here dave and and i think you know kudos
to you for having the courage to stand
up and say hey look you know i can't
believe in this stuff anymore i mean you
live out there in california you see
what is going on this is not what we're
supposed to have in a constitutional
republic and it doesn't matter r d
after a name is starting to mean less
and less it's about how you see the
relationship of the individual to the
institution of government
it's very simple the declaration of
independence says that the individual is
supreme they they are sovereign because
their rights come from a creator god if
you're atheist or whatever that doesn't
matter your rights don't come from an
entity called government your life your
liberty your property as john locke
talked about in the second treatise of
government and your pursuit of happiness
and we've got to get back to those basic
fundamentals
are you worried that just not enough
people care about what you just said
there you know last time i saw you
actually was at glenn beck's museum
where he's put together this
extraordinary
oh sorry what's the name of the museum
they i don't know
uh it's the american uh journey
experience the american journey
experience it's it's absolutely
incredible he has a trove of artifacts
that are unimaginable i mean i literally
held the olympic torch that was held by
jesse owens in front of hitler i mean i
couldn't even believe they would let me
touch that thing i mean that's just
amongst the incredible stuff that they
have but when i was there and i saw you
there
it sort of goes to what you're saying
right now
there's a history that we have there are
documents that we have that freed us
but not enough people care about them or
seem to be willing to stand up for them
are you surprised by that what can we do
to reverse that
i think it's starting to happen and you
know i will say one of the the positives
that came out of covet was that parents
actually started to see what their kids
were not being taught
and they started to pay attention and
now for the first time you never heard
about people going to school board
meetings two years ago but now they are
and they're challenging the status quo
they're challenging the institution of
indoctrination and they don't like that
and that's why they're fighting back
vehemently against it so i do think that
there's an awakening moment here in the
united states of america but you know
alexander frazier titler talked about
the cycle of democracies and he said
that a democracy can't last as a
permanent form of government it can
normally last until voters realize they
can vote their own largest from the
public treasury and one of the the pivot
points uh for that decline is apathy and
complacency and so i think that we've
seen that but it's not too late for us
to recover from it but this this is an
ideological war that we're in there's no
doubt about it between constitutional
conservatism and progressive socialism
and marxism
where do you think
some of the say disaffected liberals
maybe
libertarians
like the wider group right now that i
think i've been saying for a while it's
sort of woke versus everybody and and
it's our job it's our job as everybody
to kind of figure out how we can work
together how we can disagree and and
agree to disagree etc how do you think
that thing can work
or do you think that thing can work
i do think it can work it has to be
based upon individual rights freedoms
and liberties and you know i'll give you
guys a case in point just recently i was
up in new york city uh and you know went
out to get something to eat after you
know fox interview and everything and i
walked into this diner and guy asked me
where's your covet uh shot card and i
said i don't have a covert shot card i'm
visiting here from texas he said well
you can't eat here
i think that's going to be the thing
that you dice people because i remember
my mother and father once upon a time
they were told that they could eat in
certain places because their skin color
but now we've been told we can't eat in
certain places because someone has
decided that we have to get this thing
injected into our bodies and i really
believe that when people start to hear
that they no longer have control over
their own bodies that's going to be a
rallying cry just the same as you've
seen when uh terry mcauliffe stands up
in a debate and says parents don't have
a right to decide what their children
are being taught oh man you brought out
people in virginia that would have never
cared about a virginia gubernatorial
race and so a year ago joe biden wins
virginia by 11 and 12 points a year
later they lose virginia by two or three
points so i think that that's the shift
that we see happening when you start to
touch people's individual rights freedom
and liberty when you start to reach
inside their homes or affect their
bodies then people are going to wake up
to this yeah it used to be my body my
choice not not so much for them anymore
but you mentioned two to three points
speaking of two to three points the last
senatorial campaign in texas uh ted cruz
only beat beto by
about three points i think it was two
and a half if i'm not mistaken it was a
lot closer yeah it was a lot closer than
people thought what does that tell you
about what's happening in texas is is
austin getting weird you know filtering
throughout the state is that what's
happening
well i think that the the beta effect
that happened in 2018 was that he was a
new person and and the media built this
aura around him and there was a lot of
angst and anxiety against senator cruz
but now the the cat's out the bag and we
know who this mr o'rourke is and what he
stands for and he's completely
antithetical to texas principles and
values but when you look at what is
happening in texas when you look at what
has happened in many red states
california used to be a red state i mean
this was the state that gave us richard
nixon and ronald reagan uh what is
happening in texas is that we have had
governors going to blue states and
saying why don't you pick up and move
your business or your corporation here
uh because we have better policies and
you can economically thrive but the
thing that is happening is that as they
bring this workforce with them no one is
talking to them saying don't screw it up
when you move to this new place okay i
gotta leave california silicon valley
because this place sucks uh and so they
end up coming here and they want to vote
the same way now there are individuals
that are leaving california illinois new
york and new jersey for all the right
reasons but when you have this mass
transplant uh and i call it the locust
effect i mean people go to the you know
very good thriving fertile grounds like
california used to be and they chew it
up and destroy it and then they look and
see where else they can go but i will
tell you hats off to elon musk because
earlier in november eli must put out a
tweet to the people there in austin
saying admonishing them saying don't let
austin become the new san francisco
because the people in austin since they
defunded the police got all woke and
everything like that they've seen a 66
percent increase in violent crime 71
percent increase in homicide the
homeless situation there is absolutely
disgusting and appalling people don't go
downtown in austin at night but yet they
still voted down a proposition to refund
the police and so i think that's at the
core something that's going to to change
because all of a sudden when people
realize that their personal safety and
security is at risk
they'll back away from this
can you get those people though to
change i get that you might be able to
get the true texan that's been there you
know for a lifetime to go okay we really
gotta vote the right way but the ones
that come from silicon valley it takes
sort of a little smacking around for
them to realize that they're leaving the
thing that they voted for
it does and i think it's another thing
we have to do is teach them about you
know the history of texas or you know
the history of georgia or tennessee and
why they're successful and you know
understand that texas is the only state
in the union that fought for one it's
independence by itself uh but i think
the other thing that we have to do
without a doubt is understand that you
know find out where those strong
crossing points like you and i just
discussed well you get the 60 to 65
percent because i don't i think it's
that 35 to 40
you're probably just not going to get
through to them but let's go after the
people that understand and that's why we
had such success uh when i was the
chairman of the party going down into
the rio grande valley and we told the
people in the hispanic community who had
never seen a republican party chairman
in the rio grande valley previous to
that your principles and values are our
principles and values you know it wasn't
about the outreach it was about the
engagement outreach means you show up in
a black history month hispanic american
heritage month and then people never see
you again until a couple of months
before an election but when you're there
all the time 24 7 365 talking about
those common points that that you can
expand upon then people will rally to
your cause and again i think that this
is more of a philosophical ideological
uh cultural uh basis that we have to
approach things and not just about
political parties anymore
so i hate to do the identity politics
thing obviously and i know you don't
want to do it either but it exists
whether we talk about it or not
their battleground that that's what
they've got as you know i campaigned
with larry elder who's a good friend of
mine i saw what the machine did to him
for joe biden to show up here the day
before the election refused to say
larry's name call him a trump clone a
guy who grew up in south central l.a son
of a janitor i mean it's so
extraordinarily evil the stuff that
gavin newsom did the evil ads that reed
hastings from netflix put out about
larry blackface of white supremacy
according to l.a times you you know all
the stuff
there's obviously going to be a version
of that that's going to come after you
or you know you've been through the game
before but are you are you ready for it
in a gubernatorial thing which is
different than a congressional race and
you know being a talking head on fox et
cetera
well absolutely and one of the things
about being here in the state of texas
the republican party of texas was
founded on independence day of 1867 by
150 black men in houston texas
one of the early chairman was norris
reichoone you think about juneteenth and
you think about how recently they just
dedicated a statue to a man who was a
former slave state senator matthew
gaines who was instrumental in
establishing texas a m university and
prairie view a m university and he's
buried there at texas a m university
guess who's also buried there on the
campus of texas a m you know president
george h.w bush and his wife and so when
you talk about these things and you use
history to illuminate people and you
talk about the real party of systemic
racism has been the democrat party i
often tell folks there are two ways that
you can enslave people one is that you
work them for no pay and the other is
that you pay them for no work and tell
me which party has done that in the
history of the united states of america
so i think that as long as you stand
strong and you always go on the offense
not on the defense uh you put them back
on their heels you know
all this talk about white supremacy and
racism i have yet to see anyone on the
left speak out against margaret sanger
margaret sanger you know created planned
parenthood for one reason because she
believed that blacks were undesirables
and human weeds and yet we see 71 to 73
percent of planned parenthood clinics in
minority communities so as long as we
are the aggressor as long as we're
pinning them on their heels we don't let
them define the narrative and i think
that's the thing that the military
taught me and that's how we're going to
make sure that we don't allow them to
dictate and define who i am
are there other things going on in texas
that maybe we're not hearing about from
a national perspective that you guys are
aware of or that you think are the keys
to to winning and you know creating
flourishing state oh sure without a
doubt the property tax system that we
have here six highest in the country and
it's really marxist because here in
texas who would have ever thought you
can pay off your land you can pay off
your mortgage you can never own your
home so we've got to transition away
from that a lot of people maybe remember
this past february where texas looked
like north korea at night on a satellite
image map and we have such oil and gas
resources here we should never go into
the dark but it was an over reliance on
wind and solar so that's another big
issue for people here without a doubt
colonel west didn't aoc tell me that was
because uh they're not green enough i
thought it was because the they're not
green enough
yeah well uh i would like for her to
come down here and and spend that time
with us you know green energy may be
nice but it can only give you about
three to six percent we had wind and
solar we gave them 23 to 26 of our
energy distribution uh plan and they
just weren't able to own up to that and
so on that valentine's day in february
we went from 23 down to 3
and we did not do the winterization for
our natural gas and so those plants
weren't ready to fire up as well so uh
that's a big issue
also but without a doubt the the border
security issue and then also the
election integrity issue because there
are some people here in texas democrats
that should be in jail they should not
be walking free based upon some of the
things that they did especially down in
harris county which is the largest
county here in texas third largest and
third fourth largest in the country so
how do you address election integrity
without everyone saying you're a
conspiracy theorist or a whack job
because again when i was out there with
larry every single person i'm not
kidding you i think every single person
who came up to me to say something would
say the same two things they'd say does
larry have a chance and will it be legit
and i would always say yes to number one
and i have no idea to number two but
once you go down that path they call you
conspiracy theorists your you know all
the stuff all the stuff so how do you
tackle election integrity uh in a way
that's going to actually fix something
well i think the most important thing
you got to realize is that there are
unconstitutional actions that happen in
november 2020 no one can debate about
that in five battleground states georgia
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin and
arizona you had governors secretary of
state and judges changing election law
and sadly we even had that happen here
in the state of texas where our governor
changed early voting from two weeks to
three weeks we can't do that and so
that's unconstitutional so that's one
thing we have to tackle then we need to
make sure we have secretary of state
offices that are vetting these uh voting
machines and saying these are the
approved lists of voting machines that
we'll have in this state and if you
violate that then there has to be
consequences the problem is you can put
all the laws you want on the on the
books day but if you don't enforce them
if there are no consequences then the
left is going to continue to do exactly
that it goes right back to what joseph
stalin said it is not the person that
casts the ballot that matters it's the
person that counts the ballot that
matters and so we've got to make sure
these machines are not tied up to the
internet we got to make sure we have
paper trail audible uh uh background to
it and we also need to make sure that
the people that are supposed to be there
as poll workers whatever they're able to
do their duties but when we look at the
harris county clerk chris hollins who
opened up curbside voting locations in
nine different democratic precincts in
harris county he's still walking around
free he was gonna mail out 2.7 million
unsolicited ballots he's still walking
around free so there has to be
consequences
i literally tried to show the poll
worker my id
to vote and he would not look at it that
tells you that tells you all you need to
know i could be literally literally
anyone speaking of the election stuff so
you know texas obviously had some
election laws that were passed uh you
know georgia's had some we're sort of
seeing them pop up throughout the
country and of course the way the media
treats it this is to stop black people
somehow from voting because apparently
black people don't have id do you have
an id were you able to figure out how to
get right
let's not get your docs let's not get
your docs i'll take your word for it but
trust me verify folk there we go
we're going to blur that that could what
are you doing what are you doing that's
my license to carry card i mean the left
is no they don't want to see my license
a carry card
they definitely don't want to see that
we're going to blur it anyway connor
we're blurring that thing
save this guy save this guy's career
right now um show up at my house and
you're going to meet somebody ah fair
enough that was a challenge more than a
cell phone right there um but when you
see that you know i went through all of
the bullet points about you know showing
id about making sure that we're going to
count things properly and cameras and
you can't canvas right there then and
there but they turned the entire thing
into this is a bunch of racists trying
to stop uh minorities from voting um
just not the case just not the case
southwest airlines is racist
american airlines they'll
all these places are racist mini golf
mini golf
everything
absolutely every place that you have to
go to show an id therefore is racist and
again that comes back to what i said
dave we've got to go on offense and
we've got to just show the hypocrisy and
the the real idiocy of what these guys
were talking about because
all they had to fall back on is this
racist you know when joe biden gave his
inaugural address talk about unity he
was not talking about unity he was
talking about conformity and if you
don't conform he said we're going to
call you a racist white supremacist and
what has happened this entire year if
you don't agree with their ideological
agenda black white hispanic asian
whatever you're a racist and you're
white supremacist what about on the
mandate side of this the vaccine mandate
side of this texas has largely remained
open the couple times that i've been to
texas in the last two years have been
the rare moments of freedom that plus
florida and tennessee for me at least um
do you think abbott did basically the
right thing could could he have done
more should we all have just ignored
everything right from the beginning i
mean i think in retrospect now it's like
man we just should have told people if
you want to wear a mask wear a mask and
just get out of our way and that's it
we are dealing we were dealing with the
least most dangerous uh pandemic that
was ever seen a 99.9 recovery rate but
what did we do we destroyed people's
individual liberties and freedoms and we
can't allow that to happen and yes we
did have a shutdown here in texas that
almost lasts about 11 months
about 2.5 2.7 million texas lost jobs
about 10 000 small businesses closed and
right now we still have texans that are
losing their jobs because of some
private businesses are forcing them to
get a jab in their arm and so we have
been a lot of i think about 30
legislators in the texas state house and
senate have asked them to have a fourth
special session to make sure that they
uh you know pass the law not an
executive order but pass a law against
these mandates they've done that in
georgia they did that in florida the
legislature came back in executive
session so i think the texans want to
see a little bit more action and to make
sure that we stay one of the most free
and independent states that you have
here in the united states of america so
what this always comes down to for me i
bring it up on my show all the time is
that the states it's sort of where we
started here that the states are going
to kind of go in their separate
directions and in some ways that's okay
because of the federalist system and it
gives you more power over your state but
what do you think ideologically those
that sort of believe in what we're
talking about here what do you think we
do when they just will not leave us
alone like the to me the more that texas
florida tennessee some of those other
states flourish and it's very obvious
that they're going to flourish because
they'll bring in the right people
they'll believe in the right things the
other guys are never going to let them
alone they're going to always use them
as the scapegoat and everything else and
i could see the average person in texas
going you know i'm sick of my freaking
tax money paid to the federal government
being sent to some idiot who's voting
for gavin newsom in california i mean
that doesn't seem tenable to me for a
very long time
no you're absolutely right that's one of
the leverages that we do have here in
texas and other states are the
remittances that we send back to the
federal government because if the
federal government is not owning up to
its constitutional duties and
responsibilities like we see with the
border here then texas look and say okay
it's going to cost us x amount of
billions of dollars to get this thing
rectified and that's what we're not
going to be sending back to you as far
as from emphasis to the federal
government so everything has to come
back to the rule of law everything has
to come back to that republican form of
government which the federal government
is supposed to provide to every state in
the union and we have to stand on that
and uh i think it's so important that
just the same as the blue states came
together with the national uh popular
vote interstate compact to try to
undermine electoral college red states
need to form a wall they need to lock
shields and make sure that they are
doing what is right abiding by the rule
of law and saying that we're not we're
going to put up an impenetrable front if
you continue to try to undermine our our
freedoms and liberties in our states
remember in the declaration of
independence it says free and
independent states created these united
states of america and i think we need to
go back and reassert that have states
actually done that i actually don't know
they basically if the federal government
is in dereliction of duty they can
basically say hey we're just not going
to pay you that money that you've been
collecting from us
i think you're starting to see some
challenges you look at oklahoma right
now they're saying that they're not
going to allow the federal government to
come down and and just use their
national guard and of course there's a
fight going back there
and so but i think that that's something
that we can do it's about the power of
the person and i think states need to
understand that power that they have and
start you know strangling uh the
resources going back to the federal
government uh because right now when you
look at what the federal government is
doing with our tax dollars you just
brought it out it's going to bail out
you know blue station and failing and so
i don't think that we want to see that
happen
yeah what do you do when you have a
state that basically is doing the right
stuff and then you know we talked about
austin before there's some there's some
backwards stuff going on there what
would you as governor do if you sat down
with the mayor of austin and you felt
the policies were going in the wrong
direction when i was there last time i
you know it wasn't quite san francisco
but there's a lot of homeless etc etc
what do you do as the governor what kind
of leverage do you actually have
well i think it's first and foremost you
got to educate the electorate that lives
within that municipality and get them to
understand that this is something that
you can do by petition by referendum and
what have you but without a doubt my
responsibility is for all texans and
when i see that you have these district
attorneys that are saying we're not
going to prosecute people for anything
at 750 or less when you have these
judges here in texas that are releasing
crimes out into the streets you know
when you dig into the texas state
constitution you find that the governor
is able to impeach or start impeachment
proceedings against these judges
you have to work with the the texas
state house but you have to stay within
the rule of law you don't want to be
seen as some type of dictator or
anything like that but you got to get
people to understand that i will stand
up for the rule of law make sure that i
protect the safety and security of
individuals but you got to empower the
people to be able to do these things and
again i think that you see an awakening
toward that do you think conservatives
have to use a little more power than
they would want to perhaps
yeah you know one of the things i always
say is that republicans have to start
bringing stop bringing a plastic spoon
to a gunfight because they always just
think yeah they're not going to do
anything about it so we cannot continue
to allow them to kick sand in our face
we got to stand up and i think that's
what people are looking for and so
when we make the case i mean we win you
look at what happened in virginia look
what almost happened in new jersey uh
the left knows that they're going to
have an armageddon a political
armageddon in the midterm elections is
going to make barack obama's look you
know pretty bad i mean he lost 63 seats
in 2010 joe biden's going to lose even
more but we have to understand that we
can't have the peaks and valleys we have
to have a steady state and i tell people
that the most important elections are
those elections that are local the city
councils the school boards the county
commissions the d.a races all of those
things are the the closest to the
individual citizens down there we got to
start focusing on those
in our last couple of minutes here what
else what else is on your mind maybe not
purely political these days i know
you're also a man of faith that frames a
lot of of your beliefs of course
what else is on your mind in this
holiday season
well you know i you know college
football i love uh i love that being
brought up down south and so uh i always
get you know honed up for college
football but without a doubt i mean the
blessing of life that came into our
family with our new grandson and this
will be his uh first christmas and uh on
december the first we turned on the the
house lights and and just seeing his
face light up
you know we have many challenges that we
have here but we're still the greatest
nation that the world has ever known but
i think that now is the time when you
look at a grandson you look at our
children and grandchildren everyone just
stand up and fight for what is right and
make sure that we are not the first
generation that does not pass on
something better to subsequent
generations because again my dad was
born in 1920 and my mom was born in 1931
down south and here i am on a national
televised program talking to you dave
that's what america is all about the
equality of opportunity and not their
quality of outcomes
colonel west we live in a time with very
few people who speak as cleanly and
clearly and honestly as you do so i'm
proud to call you a friend and would you
be willing would you be willing to have
a a crazy right winger like me maybe uh
open for you on a campaign stop
larry will show you my resume it's
pretty decent i think your resume is
real decent and i'd love to to see you
here in texas because uh so goes texas
so goes american so goes america so goes
to free world so texas is important for
the free world
colonel alan west i wish you luck my
friend merry christmas to you christmas
take care dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell